it's hot
humid and now the world's fastest
warming city
kolkata on india's east coast was always
tropical but it could get four and a
half degrees celsius hotter in our
lifetime
summers are already unbearable
i don't know
foreign
the mix of rising heat and humidity for
the frail in particular is dangerous
but it's uncomfortable for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
the heat rise in kolkata is linked to
global warming but most is due to the
city itself being built without climate
change in mind
heat is trapped between the concrete
walls of densely packed tower blocks and
more are going up
environmentalist subash data has spent a
lifetime fighting this type of rapid
urbanization
filing hundreds of cases against city
planners developers and the government
they are not constantly they are
concerned about the short-term things
today's bread is more important than
tomorrow's breathe what i'll read
tomorrow don't bother about that
what i eat today is matter
politicians go on the short term things
they don't that's why there is no plan
and climate change planned does that
matter
they don't know
forget about
climate change plan
kolkata state environment minister
confirmed to us that a climate change
plan was something that had not yet been
discussed
so what does that mean for a city that
already feels like this this is the size
of a city getting hotter that you don't
really expect it's gone from being 35
degrees celsius and boiling so now
suddenly this absolutely torrential rain
this is a monsoon rain everyone you
speak to say that this isn't normal
it's the new normal
and the people that'll have to live with
this change want action
the upcoming five years has to be about
climate action if we are to secure a
habitable future for all of us
for a long time i didn't want to face it
but then i realized that it's us who has
to who have to take the charge and
do it
because now on our is yeah our leaders
will not
the rain will stop but climate change
won't
this city of extremes finds itself in a
storm with no clear way out
catherine of autopsy sky news in kolkata